sí muy buenas noches lee diana desde
nueva york pues como decías hoy estaba
prevista la intervención pregrabada como
en el caso de todos los mandatarios del
mandatario de el salvador nadie bukele
pero finalmente ha sido aplazada el
próximo 29 de septiembre a las 3 de la
tarde el último día del debate general
hemos tratado de contactar con la misión
del salvador pero de momento no han
aclarado porque este cambio
este cambio llega un día después de que
se haga público un informe elaborado por
un cinta de washington esas
organizaciones independientes que
elaboran informes relacionados entre
otras cosas con política y que vincula
directamente a funcionarios públicos y
cercanos al allí bukele con una trama de
lavado de dinero masiva que viene
también relacionada con una empresa
petrolera estatal venezolana a lo largo
de la jornada de hoy como decías hemos
escuchado a la mayoría de los líderes de
naciones africanas quienes han pedido
que se les perdone la deuda para
destinar ese dinero a hacer frente a las
terribles consecuencias del cobo y 19
también han solicitado más apoyo final
en la misma línea para hacer frente a
todos la cría la crisis económica y
sanitaria que ha dejado el hobby 19
hemos escuchado también a los
mandatarios como decías de libia y de
yemen el mandatario de libia falle zarra
ha hecho referencia al virus ese virus
ha dicho que no entiende de fronteras y
que tampoco hace diferencia entre
personas y ha pedido ante la onu apoyo
para que se celebren unas elecciones
presidenciales libres en su país también
hemos escuchado al exiliado presidente
de yemen quien ha culpado a irán
directamente de las de intrometerse en
las cuestiones de su nación y ha dicho
que quiere acabar con ese derrame de
sangre que está viviendo su país